[Music]
foreign
[Music]
hello i'm frank epstein founder
and president of collage new music
it is my pleasure to introduce you to
our latest online presentation
entitled the composer speaks
the composer speaks is an opportunity to
introduce composers
directly to you
our guest today is peter child
a long time resident of cambridge
massachusetts
and a faculty member at the
massachusetts institute of technology's
department of music
over the years we've performed many of
his chamber works
and he's a very capable composer having
written for large orchestra
and huge choruses in music that is
striking
intensely beautiful and immensely
powerful
peter will be interviewed by music
director david house
we thank you all for joining us and we
hope this experience
will bring you closer to new music and
the composers
who write it
the inevitable first question is
probably of everyone we're talking to is
what's it like
composing in this day
it's very it's very difficult i
actually completed
a large piece i think probably my
largest chamber piece
in time for an april 4th i think
was meant to be the premiere and it was
a struggle i mean it was kind of a long
time coming and it was uh
you know i i like the piece um
and uh i really worked very hard
to make sure i met that deadline and
shortly after i completed the piece and
submitted
the concert was cancelled
and um what is that piece
it's a piece that i uh
it's called six dances of death
coincidentally i feel like there's
something prophetic about this piece
actually um because it's it's it has two
principal sources one is
the series of woodcuts by
the artist the renaissance artist
holbein the younger
called the dance of death um
and the other source is the music of
henry viii
yeah um and i
sort of as this piece evolved in my
imagination it kind of stemmed from a
kind of
uh sense of some parallelisms
between the court of henry viii
his but his reputed you know extreme
narcissism
and megalomania and some of our own
you know uh the political climate that
we're living
in now here in america and so that's
what led me to want to explore this
as a topic and i did a lot of research
you know preparing for the
for the piece but then as the piece
evolved
the interaction between the musical
sources from henry viii
and the visual sources from horbine
became more prominent and it was much
more about these these
these woodcuts which are extremely
dramatic and effective and
sometimes very satirical death as a sort
of cavorting skeleton
skeletal figure is present in all of the
tableaus
um and sometimes you know if if
the person being escorted to
to their death by this figure is a
potentate
either a political or a religious
potentate
the um the feeling around the
the picture is quite satirical but
not always you know sometimes the the
the victim
or the chosen one is uh is an innocent
like a child or an
old person or a poor person and there's
there's paid thoughts there too
so i get very involved and very sort of
deeply immersed in these wood cuts
and and also i you know
really learned i studied these extant
pieces by henry viii there were about 33
of these pieces that exist and really
learned them and sort of selected the
ones i wanted to use
and um and that was the piece you know
there was a lot of research the
composition
you know there was a lot of work
involved and i struggled to meet the
deadline and i met the deadline
and then the piece was cancelled and
then after that
um i haven't really been composing
let me ask you a question about the
chamber piece you just finished
um were you asked to write this piece
um focused on the on the issues that you
ended up writing about or did were you
just asked to write a piece
and then consequently yeah you thought
about
a source of inspiration yeah it was the
latter i can't go i can't remember
far enough back because it's like it's
going back quite a while i mean this
time last year i was
i was studying these henry viii scores
and reading literature and you know in
that research
um phase of the piece so the
the very beginning sort of the embryonic
idea i can't remember exactly how that
happened
but it it is the case and this is
something that you know
because you know me well you know my
music well
um but you actually already know about
me is that
it is quite common for me
maybe even necessary for me to connect
in my
artistic work to what i'm experiencing
in the world around me
or in my personal life how often do you
end up
composing music without
a performance in mind just for your
own edification i i honestly can't
remember the last time i composed
a piece certainly a sub you know
substantial piece that wasn't
with a particular performer and an
eventual performance
already sort of in mind so
um i sometimes think that that
would be i'm attracted to the idea in
principle but in practice
being able to imagine the the players
that i'm going to be working with or the
singers you know the musicians i'm going
to be working with
is part of the process for me i think
but who knows that might have to do so
when you get started writing a piece
for instance this chamber piece do you
ever get stuck
unable to figure out what to do and
what do you do when you get stuck
because it's hard to imagine
yeah anyone doesn't get stuck right
so no the beginnings of pieces
especially begin especially big pieces
can
can feel quite i can feel quite
full-on actually and hopeless
particularly if the generative idea
isn't there
if i know that um you know
if the commission is there a deadline is
there you know the
the the necessity to write the pieces
there but the the artistic
um embryonic idea isn't there then that
i can feel you know
it can feel quite desperate the the odd
thing about that
is that it some uh degree of desperation
happens almost every time oh my god i'm
never going to be able to put
put pen to i'm never going to write
another piece that's it i'm done
um uh so evidently that's also part of
the process if i take a if i step back
far enough and uh and think about that
and realize
actually you know it's it's
a part you know it's a moment and i get
over that moment and
uh and get going again
to some degree well to some degree i
i have found that you know i i
i have to trick myself i think part of
the problem is and you know it depends
on the scale of the piece
so the problem the problem is is
often if it's a big piece smaller pieces
are less troubling
from this in this way but if it's a big
piece it's that sense
of wanting to be able to imagine the
whole and knowing that the whole
is so far away there's so much work you
know there's so
there's so much distance there's so much
about the peace what the peace will
eventually be that i
not only don't know but cannot possibly
know in advance
that um it's just so overwhelmingly
daunting
and that's the thing i have to sort of
escape from sort of protect myself from
that feeling
of feeling overwhelmed so the tricks so
the tricks i play mostly are mind games
you know do
little quotes okay i don't have to solve
these big problems all i have to do is
work for 30 minutes and i'll show you
something let's just get off camera for
a second
there's something that my wife bought
for me
it's a it's an egg timer or a it's a
timer
and it's it's 30 minutes from beginning
to end
it was actually kind of typical of her
that she kind of she knows me well
enough to know how much use i would get
out of this
and if i have a task that's daunting and
overwhelming there's just so
there's just i i can't see myself from
beginning to end i said well actually
all i have to do
is turn this over and work with it and
and work until that's done
or do my best to work until that's done
and then i can do something else
and it's my it's a trick um
and almost and it just relieves me from
that pressure and enables me to work
and almost always by the time this runs
out i want to keep keep going
do you find yourself sketching things
and throwing most of them away or
are or do you actually not
commit to anything on the page and then
suddenly you're
and then you find yourself able to move
now
and you don't back up no it varies it
absolutely very rarely back up very
rarely throw anything
out i might have an idea that
uh that gets uh you know table and i
don't find a place for it
right away but i already throw anything
out but sketching is very important
to me and um
you know just just an idea that you know
that might be a sort of
sort of an imagined figure
um it might be an improvised figure that
i write down and i think yes okay that's
that's something do you find that
do you find those ideas that you can't
find a place for
right now not even finding a place in
this piece but some
later time in some other piece there is
an idea that you had a year ago
yes yeah i have come across
old sketches that i forgot that i'd ever
made that have
you know found a place
and actually helped me and saved me in
some situations
that end up being fertile yes yeah
yeah but sketching that's right i mean
that's also a
it's not you know that's also important
because a sketch is only a sketch it's
not a there's no commitment there
just an idea and um
and i think the other thing with me is i
think the process the compositional
process at every
level is a slow one you know some people
are very fast
and i i certainly envy them their speed
you know
but for me the process is a very slow
one so and so i might have an idea
write down the idea and usually that i
think there's something even in the
sort of um the graphic that you know the
way the idea is written down that
emblematizes its provisional nature
because it's almost always
almost illegible right so
a kind of a shape or a gesture yeah yeah
yeah or
just something that's written so um
the word is scheduling you know so with
so little detail sort of just hinting at
what the actual idea is
that if i'm not careful if i leave it
too long i i it's quite hard to decode
sometimes afterwards and i think there's
something deliberate about that
that's another part of the mind game i'm
sorry i'm not really committing to this
just writing this
idea down but it but part of the
slowness i think is
figuring out what the possibilities of
my ideas
actually are so sleeping on you know
doing
the composition is important but
actually being away from the
being away from the music and letting
i think it's letting my unconscious mind
work on it
is very much an important part of the
process for me
how often do you find once once it's
past a sketch stage and it's actually on
the staff paper and there are pitches
and rhythms
how often do you find yourself making
changes
wholesale changes and how often do you
find yourself making
little changes which might be very
important changing that
g sharp to a b natural or that rhythm
rhythmic gesture tightening it or
freeing it up
do those kinds of changes take place yes
i think that happens
all the time i mean i don't kind of keep
a mental record of it but i think it
happens all the time and a lot of it
happens of course in the rehearsal
process
as well you know you discover
discover and of course it depends who
you're rehearsing with i mean
one of the things that i appreciate
greatly and have over what is now
decades of
professional association with you you
know
is that is this kind is that i feel that
our process
is very much a collaborative process and
i've often
found your suggestions which are often
rather concrete to be very helpful
well that's very nice but i don't i hope
i don't say well
i think that g should be a g-sharp uh or
seldom i hope
um i i would have to really think that
if anything quite like that has ever
happened but
you know we've you have certainly made
suggestions
about orchestration that i've taken on
board and incorporated and things like
that
and learned a lot from and by the way i
i convey
to my students um
i mean i think our relationship is a bit
special in that way i don't
think that's true of my interaction with
all the performers that i like to work
with but
um but i do convey a sort of a as a life
lesson to
to my composition students that a piece
of music is not
completed until it's been performed and
and what i mean by that is you need to
hear it you need to
you you need to hear it but you also
need to experience the music that you
wrote
that as a kind of an interactive medium
with the players and what they're giving
back to you know you need to learn about
the piece from what the players do with
[Music]
it
[Music]
peter your wife lena is a very
distinguished visual artist
um i i don't think of your
your music and her visual art as
very similar she's more of a conceptual
artist
but i'm wondering if you see connections
between your music
and her her
pieces or something similar about
your working styles or even different
that would be of interest to us
well the working styles i think probably
are different in one very significant
way that they're different is has to do
with your last question and
she will work in intense spurts for a
particular show
and then put it all aside you know until
the next intense but
happens or the next deadline um
her artistic
sensibility and especially her education
and goal goals artistically
are from mine
they're radically different from what
mine used to be
but of course you know in the 10 years
since she and i have been
together i've been really kind of
intellectually and artistically in terms
of artistic sensibility kind of
rubbing shoulders with her trying to cut
you know
trying to understand her work um
and being brought back in touch with
a um some impulses some artistic and
intellectual impulses that for me
were kind of part of my history part of
who i
am but were very much dormant you know
because as a student
i was interested in what basically the
musical equivalent of conceptual
art which is cage and aleatoric music
and
and things of that kind and um
so interacting with leaner around
subjects of art
has sort of reinvigorated some of those
early interests and enthusiasms of mine
reignited them as well and
um and actually it's given me kind of a
shot in the arm it's kind of broadened
what i what i try to do
musically and uh
you know a big impetus for that is that
i do a lot i almost always do something
in connection with her shows you know if
she has a
um an opening and if there's an
opportunity for me to
to to do a piece um
either for a performer or more typically
for myself to perform then i'll do it
and that's led me to duels all sorts of
things that are that
are really you know musically
you know have added to you know the
the range of possibilities that you know
i see in my music it's really had a kind
of a profound effect
so i've done electronic pieces i've done
pieces that involve electronics and
and narration that i've performed at her
openings i've done a piece for prepared
piano
that um that i performed at the piano
as an accompaniment to lena reading some
of her texts
you know things that i are unlike
anything
i have done in all again all the years
or decades since you and i have one
known one another since graduate school
in brandeis you know really connecting
to something that was
part of me before that time so it's
actually been in terms of
both what i do creatively and how i
think about music and art it's been an
expand
a process of expansion and um
i think rejuvenation you know for me
are some of those um characteristics
that you find
in your music or that emerge in your
music when you're writing a piece for
one of lena's shows
do they begin to show up in your
concert music yeah absolutely
so i i did a piece a few years ago
um a recorded piece that took just a
simple line of text
and i subjected it to a the simple line
text i recorded it myself
my own voice with this one line of text
and then basically
subjected that recording to increasingly
dense layers
of um of interference you know an
expansion
until eventually it was that the words
were indistinguisha indistinguishable as
words
and it was just with just sort of sounds
electronic sounds in the end
and when i got done i when i so the
performance of that piece
was just a matter of pressing the start
button on a on a
recording device but uh when i got done
another artist friend of
lena's and somebody who had become i've
become very friendly with
and who was himself also a conceptual
artist came up to me he said something i
actually made
made me really think about what i'd done
not just in that piece but what i had
been doing in
other pieces prior to that one what
subsequently became a sense of
of my uh of what i
think of as my process and my style and
he said
he said he said the piece is like a
mantra.
he didn't say very much about it you
didn't even elaborate on on it very much
but
you know he made this remark and i
thought about it and i thought first of
all that's a kind of
a very positive way to describe this
otherwise rather repetitive
you know cyclical form
um but that i
i you know i realized that actually and
quite a lot of music that i'd written
prior to that piece or to the experience
or prior to
you know lena's influence had that form
it was it was the form of
musical ideas stretches of ideas that
at one level appeared to be repeating
that were cyclical but were never
exactly the same
from one iteration to the next i'd
already been doing it
it shows up in that orchestral piece
shanti that i wrote and some um
a piece called meditations upon the lamb
which is a choral piece actually
and it's called meditations upon the
land because it incorporates texts about
the lamb
and i then subsequently i took that on
board as i kind of said yes i'm doing
this already and that yes this is
something i
i think is a stamp uh
and kind of an interesting way to
sort of an interesting formal notion for
me to pursue
and so quite a lot of my pieces are like
that now
some movements in lamentations the piece
the last piece that i wrote for the
cantata singers i like that
elegy the elegy with rabbit that you
alluded to earlier that collage
performed is very much like that
you know the idea that the idea that
thing cycles are repeating and you sort
of listen and you think
actually i'm hearing the cyclicity and
yet nev
things are never exactly the same
and i like the idea of taking that
notion and stretching it out but also
stretching it to danger point
you know um
you know taking it just about as far as
you can
you can take it without losing your
audience
and then releasing so let me ask one
more question and then
we should let you go um i
you said that this particular time that
we're in
has is proving difficult for you to
compose
um partly because you finished a large
piece and maybe there's not something
you know pushing on you to write the
next piece
um but do you have something
that you are conjuring up
yes so i i'm just going to get off
screen for a second because
i i actually
through a colleague who's a medievalist
i discovered a
early renaissance hymn that's
a response to the plague
or actually the not the series of
plagues
you know after the black death that
visited themselves upon europe
and it's the text is stellar chile chele
exterpalit
and there are several settings of this
music in existence some chance settings
and some
polyphonic settings but it's one of the
few pieces
that was where the text was composed
you know appealing actually to to me to
the virgin mary to intercede on behalf
of the sick
and intercede with the constellations
that are visiting these terrible
you know diseases upon us all um
and and was and the hymn was apparently
used in services
that you know that addressed
these troubles and
you know to the
to the medieval people in the middle
ages and
the uh early renaissance period who were
visited by these plagues it must have
felt
you can't imagine but it didn't feel
something like what we're feeling
now the the known world
was visited by the by by this invisibles
um you know
inscrutable phenomenon
that could rob you not just you of your
life but you
rob you of your loved ones almost
overnight
you know it was a very swift the plate
was very swift
disease so i'm what's cooking
but i had to reach over and get this off
my um
my music stand is an idea of somehow
incorporating this text or
possibly as i did with the henry the
eighth
piece incorporating some of the existing
settings
uh of that text as source materials of a
new piece
either either a vocal piece or possibly
even an instrument
an instrumental piece but yeah but it's
it's just another example of how for me
what's going on in my personal life and
in the world around me
is such an important part of what i of
what informs what i want to do
as a composer well if the topic of
or the focus of this
possible composition that you will may
be working on in the next months
is not the most optimistic one it is
a wonderful thing that you are thinking
about writing music because you are a
very special
composer and uh i
personally and i think many many people
will look forward to
hearing not only the piece that you have
just recently
completed but also the one that you are
about to write
peter thank you so much for this time
your eloquence and your thoughts about
the world of composition we're grateful
i enjoyed it
it's always wonderful to see you and
talk to you likewise
peter wrote his elegy for
an ensemble of flute clarinet
violin cello piano percussion
um shortly after his father passed away
and after a period that peter
had said was a fallow period
his father had been quite ill and he was
taking care of him
and this piece was
both his coming back out into the world
of composition
after a quiet period and also a response
to his father's passing away
it's a very beautiful piece it's direct
in its language and quite eloquent and
touching
[Music]
my
[Music]
um
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
um
[Music]
so
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Music]
you